[Music]
Jimmy rain is the founder and CEO of
Great Southern wood preserving based in
Abbeville Alabama
Great Southern is one of the country's
largest treaters of lumber so basically
they take raw lumber from other
companies Sawmills primarily and apply
chemical preservatives to ensure that it
lasts a lifetime
and based on great Southern's two
billion dollars of 2022 sales we
estimate that the company's worth about
one billion dollars
[Music]
Jimmy actually took over the company
when the father of his first wife
tragically died in a car accident in
1970.
he was a farmer
and like what most Farmers he was
playing rich but cash poor
so the CPA that was advising the family
said sell the tractors sell the plow
sell all the personal property but don't
sell any land
and this little treating plant sat on
six and a half acres of land next to the
farm
and so they did that they sold
everything except this one little
treating plant and they had one offer
from Mr Ralph Reynolds here in Abbeville
he was a pulpwood dealer he offered them
14 000 for the little treating plant
and that and the six and a half acres
that it sat on
the brother wanted to take it my wife
was trying to do what the CPA told her
so they kind of got in a disagreement
and I was in law school trying to
mediate my first case so I came up with
the idea that I would lease the land
and sell the equipment so I made an
offer to them well I'll buy the
equipment for ten thousand dollars and
I'll lease the land
and everything will go away and I'll
stay in law school and I'll finish so my
father said Jimmy that's a very good
idea but what happens if you can't sell
it you're going to sign a note for ten
thousand dollars but if you can't oh
that I can sell it for sure I can sell
it but what if you can't anyway he was
right I couldn't sell it
so now I've got a treating plant
so I finished Law School and came back
here and opened a one-room law office on
the four and a half Square two black
telephones this was Ring I'd say Jimmy
rain law office this one ring I'd say
Great Southern wood preserving so that's
how I started me and one other fellow
awesome Curry
back then the company was doing less
than a hundred and thousand dollars of
sales so for action of you know what it
does today the head no cash no money
and money is the lifeblood of any
business and I struggled for a long long
time
trying to run the business I would get
up 4 30 in the morning and go out meet
Lawson and we would get everything ready
and start treating come back and take a
shower could practice law until 4 30
then I'd go back and stay with him until
we got finished things really started to
take off in the mid 80s when Jimmy
attended a Harvard Business School
program for the owners and managers of
family-owned private companies and he
was inspired by a case that he studied
there about how Frank Perdue used
marketing effectively to turn commodity
chicken into a household name every time
I would walk into a building supply
store and try to talk to them about my
product
the only question they asked what's your
price
and
I knew we had the best product I knew we
had the highest quality I knew the
extent that we were going to to make a
high quality product and to give service
but it didn't matter so I needed some
way to get the attention of that dealer
I wanted to find some emotional thread
that would weave through my area and
that was college football Jimmy had this
Insight based on his love of college
football and the love of college
football across the South that if he
were to bring in the big college
football coaches not only at his alma
mater Auburn but at rival Alabama and
others throughout the South if you were
to bring them in as spokespeople that
would you know really help grow his
brand and that certainly turned out to
be the case I had known Pat for a long
time we became friends but when he got
the job at Auburn in 81
and I went to Harvard in 84 85 and 86.
and the idea came to me when I was at
Harvard to try and use marketing to
differentiate my product so I came back
and I talked to Pat about it first
and he'd say well we'll try it see how
it works like this fence built most
pressure treated pine from Great
Southern wood the lumber with a 40-year
guarantee speaking of extra defense
ring in let me keep this so after years
of doing commercials with the coaches
he'd sort of actually created this own
character and brand for himself and you
could argue maybe at that point he
didn't really need the coaches as much
so when he was thinking about you know
with his marketing team what the next
phase of the company's advertising would
look like
he ended up drawing on his love for old
westerns and created this character
called the yellow fella who is a cowboy
played by Jimmy
when we first started we were using
actors and nothing was catching on Marty
Marshall was my marketing professor at
Harvard and so I talked to Marty and he
said well he said I think the problem
you're having is that
people are not connecting it's just
another commercial I really didn't have
any plans to be on camera but they walk
in one day and had this uh
storyboard for this cartoon cowboy and I
said do you you really want me to do
that it was really
I thought hokey cartoonish
and it sort of evolved into yellow
fellow
who are you Mr fella
yellow fella
[Music]
fella I thought you were dead
not hardly
I wanted to replicate the Roy Rogers
Gene Autry John Wayne figures of my
youth being in your 60s and not playing
Cowboys and Indians was a lot of fun I
mean we were shooting these commercials
in the location that John Ford and John
Wayne used it was like being a kid again
riding horses and shooting guns and I
mean you just don't think about
the other side effect said okay then
when people see this
they're going to recognize you so but
that was kind of different for me I I
said I came here to rebuild the town
with Yellowwood best there is for
building Outdoors
Abbeville Alabama where Jimmy lives
today and where he started the company
and has kept it ever since it's probably
not exactly where you would expect to
find the richest guy in Alabama it's a
small town of 2 000 people about a three
hour drive from Atlanta Jimmy grew up
there his family had been there long
before he was born and he's chosen to
keep his company there and live there
today and I think a big part of the
attachment that he feels is the critical
role that his own dad of everyone in
Abbeville knows as Mr Tony played in the
town's development in the 1950s my dad
was a real entrepreneur he came back
here after World War II he wanted to
open a nice restaurant than he did it
was called The Village Inn well Mr Homer
Carter was president of pepper
Manufacturing in Opelika
and so he used to come through
Abbeville on his way to his Beach House
at Panama City and he loved to stop at
the restaurant and need to add spaghetti
so Mr homwell came in one day and he
started asking dad he said Tony he said
what kind of town do you all have here
what kind of water supply what kind of
Mayor I've got a plant that I want to
build and open it's a textile plant and
I'm trying to find a location to
to put it so they started talking and
giving them all this information he said
well can you get the president the Sam
of Commerce
and he said we don't have a chance he
said oh well I'm sorry we can't come in
a place they don't have a chance we'll
get you one so they organized one and he
became the first president and Mr
Carter's decision was between Abbeville
and Cuthbert Georgia
and I always say that dad's spaghetti is
the one that won it so he chose
Abbeville and they came to town with 25
employees and they started sewing Uptown
on the Square and they grew that plant
from 25 to 1400.
[Music]
to live here and grow up here was
idyllic I mean it was everything that
you've ever seen in old movies and that
was what it was like and then NAFTA came
along and destroyed at that time that
building set on 53 acres and 550 000
square feet on the roof
huge plan I mean it was terrible and
from then through the 90s if you rode
through Abbeville in 1996
it'll lock the door and kept going it
was burned out buildings and boarded up
buildings it was just a devastated
community
So within the last few years that plant
was still sitting empty and years ago to
avoid it being sold to a salvager Jimmy
bought the plant and paid years worth of
taxes and an interest and the like
before he could figure out what to do
with it and then in 2018 hurricane
Michael happened and demand for wood
basically went through the roof and the
company went to its suppliers the
Sawmills and said we need x amount of
wood and they couldn't meet that demand
so in order to cushion the company
against future situations like that
Jimmy actually opened one of his
company's first Sawmills at the old
Pepperell plant in Abbeville in 2019 I
think that was a moment of Pride for him
he went from being the model for years
to now
we got about 110 people out there making
an average of twenty two dollars an hour
so that's been sort of a great
inspiration to me that we were able to
bring that back and bring that kind of
prosperity back and it's made a big
difference in the town when you look at
our sales tax revenue and just the whole
economy around Abbeville has really been
improved because of that facility
thanks to the success Jimmy's had he's
been able to really give back to that
community and he's spent you know
millions of his own dollars to to
revitalize the town to look like it did
when he was a kid I wanted to build
hugging mollies because it brought back
a time for me
that was very special when I was a kid I
would go uptown on the Square to Central
drug store and you'd go in there after
school and you'd get a fountain drink so
we tried to replicate Central drugstore
with hugging Molly with the soda
fountain in the stools and the
carbonated water and the drinks most of
the buildings downtown have been
replicated back to the way they were
originally constructed and rather than
build one giant big office building we
would put different offices in some of
the buildings so it would bring the
building back to life and it would bring
the town back to life and we tried to
go back and restore them as I remembered
them in the 50s
[Music]
Jimmy started this foundation called the
Jimmy rain Foundation which is education
focused and funds partial scholarships
for college students and the way that
the foundation funds itself is primarily
through a charity golf tournament but it
runs every year one of our employees she
had a daughter and a son and the little
I knew both of them very well and the
little girl
was just such a bright shining child her
whole life all she talked about was I
want to be a doctor
and she never wavered from kindergarten
through grade school through High School
so she went to Auburn her father ran a
Thai store here and her mother worked
for arts and accounting
and at that time
Auburn didn't have a great scholarship
program but
trying to help her and she got a small
one
I guess I became distracted I don't know
but her father died passed away
and before I really knew it
she had dropped out of college because
she couldn't afford it
oh that just broke my heart it
devastated me and uh I said this is not
right but it's not right we can't we got
to do something I don't know what we're
going to do something
so we decided right then and there that
we were going to start this Foundation
and we were going to make sure it was
the best we could that wasn't going to
happen again Jimmy has been able to draw
on the relationships that he made over
so many years working with the college
coaches to you know bring in big names
like Peyton Manning whose dad was in a
commercial with Jimmy Herschel Walker
who was you know a big name Georgia
running back so his ability to bring
those big names is really a big draw for
people who want to pay to play in the
tournament and as a result of that the
foundation's been able to fund more than
500 partial scholarships to date in the
first year we raised money we didn't
have enough money to give a scholarship
the next year we gave one
and then the next year we get two and
now we give over 50 a year and we've
gone out over 560.
and I said that first night I said I
hope I'm standing here and we give out a
thousand
God willing I will
[Music]
foreign